foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we're dead as dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships this is the
Ramsay show the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
the call is free and some say the advice
is worth exactly what you pay for it but
I got a special treat for you guys right
now we are going to spend a few moments
here introducing our newest Ramsay
personality money personality Jade
warshaw welcome thanks Dave thanks for
having me this is exciting stuff man hey
this is everybody's gathered around all
of your biggest fans in the building
which is everybody I see them out there
and uh they're gathered around to watch
this small moment happen this has been
going on a while of course you've been
with the team for a while and today we
bring you on the air for the first time
and you folks will be hearing from her a
lot more in the coming months the coming
years at events with books with uh
showing up here on this microphone as we
answer questions about your life and
your money so what brings you for the
sake of the audience I know but what
brings you here give us a little bit of
your background I'll be happy to Dave
you know my background is actually not
in money and I tell people that my
background is actually an entertainment
I was a vocalist for 15 years Dave
professionally my husband and I
performed over 92 countries all around
the world and when we came out of Music
School we did we we found out we
discovered Dave that we had close to
half a million dollars of debt 460
thousand dollars of debt is what we had
good Lord unbelievable and uh you know I
tell people all the time I'm not talking
about like like Mortgage Debt Dave this
is Consumer Debt this is credit cards
Dave this is for music schools music and
you know Dave music school you know
which is known for paid big pay oh and
you know how good musicians manage money
like almost as good as athletes there's
a reason for The Stereotype yeah
absolutely yeah so it was all student
loan debt or most of it was no most of
it was student loan debt 280 000 of it
Dave was student loan debt can you
believe that unbelievable and so um we
knew we needed to make a change and uh I
had heard of you before I remember uh
years ago I had heard you on the car and
my in my brother's car you were on the
radio talking about debt I'm pretty sure
you were calling somebody stupid and
kicking their butt but in that moment it
was you Dave yeah and you were kicking
our butt too and I told Sam I was like
man I think we need to do this Dave
Ramsey thing and uh from then on we got
serious we started we started the plan
and um in seven and a half years Dave we
were able to pay off every single cent
of 460 thousand dollars of debt and if I
could add because I know I know whenever
I say that people are like oh you must
have had like this you know this big
income or you must have like magic beans
or something like that I'm telling you
guys when we came out of college we got
married one week Dave after graduation
and I mean when I tell you we had no
jobs we had no prospects we had no money
all we had was that 460 000 of debt and
our income was super low because
musicians you know our income at the
time starting out day was 30k
well that was starting though that was
starting look I tell people all the time
you got to work there's a like you say
all the time there's a wonderful place
to go and you don't have any money
that's to work and that's what we did we
started of course we were in the
entertainment thing so we were doing
gigs and that started picking up but you
know what Dave I attribute a lot of this
because I think that when you decide to
submit to a plan something really
magical happens and you start getting
when you say I want to work and I'm
willing to work you start to receive
opportunities to work and you start to
see them everywhere and when you say I'm
going to do that then then that's what
you do so we started working everywhere
I mean at one point we were traveling 35
weeks out of the Year internationally
doing shows and then in between the
shows we would pick up side gigs I'm
talking about we were doing everything
my husband was teaching lessons I was
teaching lessons I would bake cupcakes
and sell the cupcakes uh my husband
would design websites at one point I got
a job working at a tent and vinyl
lettering company and so I would go in
there in the daytime and the first half
of the day I would install tint on the
windows and then in the second half of
the day I would put vinyl letters on
work trucks so if you've ever seen a
truck that says like I don't know like
Bubba's Roofing and where bub is heating
and cooling yeah you did it those
letters were straight Dave those letters
they were on there you guys were getting
it man y'all were y'all were stepping
and fetching I mean you were getting
after it you uh the hustle and grind
find the grit and to pay off 460 000 in
seven and a half years you don't do that
uh sitting around and people handing you
money you went and got money and caused
it to happen it's a big deal oh yeah and
you know one of the things that we
talked about you and Sam and Sharon and
I were at dinner when we were talking
about you guys coming on board here and
you said growing up your family had a
saying and you don't want to ever hear
that saying again oh yeah you know
growing up you know my parents they did
the best they could with what they had
and um you know I think as in in so many
American families you know that paycheck
to paycheck it's real you know and I
used to hear all the time we ain't got
no money you know by the time the end of
the month rolls around we ain't got no
money you know and I just uh it just
frustrated me to no end and you know I
I'd been there so many times that by the
time I got married and knew that I
wanted a family that was a phrase that I
vowed I would not say now we can we can
save up money until we can afford to do
things and we can say no temporarily but
that's a whole different mindset than
just saying I ain't got it I ain't got
no money that that that is a phrase that
will not be in my vocabulary other than
to teach others how to get out of that
mentality yeah and warning already I'll
let some of you know if it's in your
vocabulary uh she's gonna remove it oh
I've gotten permit I've gotten
permission to kick some butts in here
Dave I I'm ready y'all gave me formal
permission to kick butts it's in the
contract it's in the contract oh yeah
okay so talk about with the team what
you're going to be doing with the Ramsey
team here so you know the big thing for
me is is baby step two y'all are gonna
hear me talk about baby step two all the
time because we spent seven and a half
years there I know how to get out of
that I know how to motivate you I know
how to set your mind right so that
you're going to start working and uh I
hope to do that a lot of that co-hosting
the show you know with the team the
Ramsay show uh we've got some live
events coming up in the spring Building
Wealth I'll be a part of those some of
those events and you know it's been
really fun I've been working a lot with
the Financial Peace University City team
so I think you're going to see me as
part of that so we've got some we've got
some things planned we got some plans in
the work Dave it's going to be good I
saw a thing you guys were working on Six
Figure Freedom come on that's a good
phrase Dave I almost come out of my
chair when you said that six figure
Freedom this is what this is all about
you know I read a stat that said the
average Millennial has a hundred and
seventeen thousand dollars of debt
Consumer Debt again not Mortgage Debt
and I think to myself you know people
say oh Jade you had 460. that's that's
the high the high end of the 460 right
or of the six figures but people come in
at 117k that's the norm now and I said
there is something in this six figure
Freedom club we are going to make sure
that the content is there to keep you
motivated keep you moving forward and
you will pay off six figures a day you
can tell me you won't do it Dave but do
not tell me that you can't
don't say we ain't got no money she's
not gonna accept it I'm just telling you
I love it Jade warshaw ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the team
awesome times here at Ramsey folks
awesome times this lady's on fire you
guys are going to grow to love her as we
have very very quickly
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com Ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Ty is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
in case you couldn't tell that free
screams are kind of a big deal around
here the folks who stand on this stage
are heroes the people who call in and
are debt free tell their story are
heroes they chose to live like no one
else and now they get to live and give
like no one else so we came up with the
idea of the live and give box so it's
got goodies in it it's got The Total
Money Makeover book over a million
copies sold that's a good one to give
but you might want to keep it uh you can
get an entire year of Financial Peace
University and you get the latest number
one bestseller baby steps millionaires
all of this in one box keeps some of it
give some of it it's the live and give
box
99 dollars that's a deal along with a
bazillion other deals obviously for the
Christmas holidays all at Ramsey
Solutions so ramsesolutions.com be sure
and check out the store there if you
want the living give boxes
ramsesolutions.com box Madison is with
us in Columbus Ohio hey Madison welcome
to the Ramsay show
hi George it's an honor and a privilege
a long time listener first time caller
well thank you how can we help today
um it's actually a career question I'm
27 years old I'm a registered nurse I
just left my specialty of seven years
for what I thought was my dream job
um I thought I was leaving for a job
that was a perfect fit and I was super
excited to start but I'm slowly
realizing that it's a very toxic work
environment and it's not what I signed
up for I've pretty much decided that
it's not a good fit for me mentally and
physically I'm just asking of how I need
to proceed to leave on the best terms
possible
wow I'm sorry
thank you you got another
gig you can go to obviously in nursing
right
yes yes and I'm trying to find something
that I'm honestly passionate about I
think the most frustrating part about
all of this is that I really felt like I
put the time into real uh
making sure that this was a good fit
move into my career what'd you miss I'm
sorry what did you miss
leadership
leadership I think that's my biggest
problem right now and that's something
that I can't change you know
I'm just saying if I you know I'm trying
to if you stepped in a trap once before
I would want to know what that trap
looks like and smells like if you're
going if you're going through the forest
again right
yes and
I feel like I've learned a lot
okay
how would you describe the environment
you're saying it's a toxic workplace
there's not good leadership what does
that look like in the day to day
chaos
um I really feel
um kind of the back story of this is
that um the person that is training me
um he actually fired and I am now
expected to step into this position too
many icky things have happened and I
just don't feel right about it you know
it's just not who I want to be working
under as somebody who wants to be in a
leadership position
okay so you've got I've got people that
are struggling with Integrity they're
struggling with communication they're
struggling with organizational skills
um
you know who they are and
um you cannot control how they react
although we can fairly predict it
yes I mean who you just described to me
is probably not going to react with
class
no and I've already seen it yeah so
um that doesn't change who you are it
changes it just States who they are and
so the only the only thing you can do is
a don't expect an alligator to do
anything but be an alligator
number one so don't set your
expectations this regardless of what you
do that somehow you're going to make
these people be something other than
toxic because they're probably going to
react in a toxic manner just be ready
for that brace yourself right
um that doesn't Define you that defines
them and that doesn't uh also on the
second part of the equation then is it
also doesn't uh dictate how you handle
this you handle this not based on them
but based on you
you're a person of class
you're a person of Integrity uh and so
you're going to be that person here and
so you're going to be calm
and kind
and direct
and they're by the way there's no reason
to critique them on the way out it will
do no good
nope nope
that's just standard exit interview crap
that they're not going to take the
advice or they would have already been
doing all these things
this is
I personally don't believe in exit
interviews we do them at Ramsey because
a bunch of my leadership team disagrees
with me and I acquiesce and let them do
them but I don't need an exit interview
I'm staying I'm going to keep it being
who I am and I don't really give a crap
what your opinion is if you're leaving
so I'm that that's me that may be toxic
but it is what it is I'm I'm staying
you're not so why do I care what you
think you know so anyway besides that
these people aren't going to listen
and you're not you're no longer my point
of that whole rant was you're not in a
position of credibility once you've quit
to influence decisions there the only
way you got you can influence decisions
there is stay in with your shoulder to
the wheel but once you've decided to
leave you're not in a position of
influence
so do what's best for me and my family
yeah very quickly quietly calmly
with as few sentences and as few things
in writing as possible other than just
thank you for the opportunity this whole
situation is just different than I
thought it was it doesn't line up with
the way I think and I just I can't do
this and I am so sorry
um and gosh thank you for letting me try
and thank you for the opportunity and
I've just I've accepted a thing at the
end of the place bye and it's just
really really really really short
thank you so much I have this this gave
me a lot of guidance yeah just be very
very
kind and quiet and quick
um there's no the decisions made there's
nothing that's going to change the
decision by having a long discussion and
you're going to get drawn into
their web of garbage if you start having
a discussion about it
because you're gone thank you you're
gone you already told me you're gone
there's nothing they can do they'll make
you stay right
yes yeah so the decision is made it's
just now a matter of executing it and
again uh you're a person of Class A
person of Integrity so leave with lots
of class and smile and grateful thank
you for letting me try this I'm so sorry
it didn't work out
um and gosh I wish you guys the best I
hope everything works well and
you know
good luck with your toxic bad self and
so
a lot of people feel like I owe my
employer all of this when I'm leaving
and so it's like a breakup when you're a
teenager you don't want to drag it out
and make it this big emotional process
if it's done it's done and it's we have
to be adults and just move on and you
know truthfully the same is true on the
other side of the coin uh the way we
train leadership here on the way we
train entree leaders is
if you're going to work with someone and
give that person a bunch of input
do that before you fire them
you know so I'm gonna we're gonna work
together
we're gonna have some difficult
conversations I'm going to say this
activity this Behavior this attitude uh
whatever it is
that has to change you know you're going
to do better you're going to prosper if
you adopt these character qualities
you're you know we're going to walk with
you and help you and Coach you uh and if
you don't then you can't be a we because
we do it this way and so we're going to
talk about being a we talk about it talk
about it talk about it talk about it but
once we've decided that that the
relationship as far as employment is
going to end uh the exit for the person
is about a minute and a half long as
quickly as possible it's just uh you
know we've been talking about this and
I'm so sorry but we don't we we don't
think it's going to work anymore and
today's your last day and so uh HR will
help you with the paperwork and we're
going to give you we've agreed to give
you a severance of this much and uh gosh
any way we can help you out there in the
world we'll help you any way we can but
we don't believe that there's a change
that's going to happen anymore and boom
it's I mean quitters do not survive that
day no it's we we don't do it's very
very loud in this not in the sense of
yelling but it's very crystal clear and
long before we got to
uh quiet firing or it wouldn't be quiet
firing it would be uh loud firing a
direct clear firing there we go long
before we got that with a quiet quitter
we would have had these discussions like
coaching and you know this idea plan
mediocrity is your goal you ain't a Wii
we don't do mediocrity We're Going For
Excellence we're trying to win the Super
Bowl so you're not going to fit in we we
we go for it and so if you want to be a
Wii you got to go for it we would have
had that discussion and then we would
have the quiet quitting would have
ceased
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Merry Christmas America
we're glad you're with us the phone
number here is triple eight eight two
five five two two five Jesse is with us
in Pennsylvania how are you Jesse
I'm doing great Dave hey before we get
started I'd just like to say thank you
outside of other than my immediate
family you and one other person have
probably been the biggest influences of
my life and I want to thank you for that
oh my goodness Merry Christmas I'm
honored thank you Merry Christmas I mean
I I grew up on a farm and um you know
our our farm trucks that haul the hay
bales and stuff the only am radios in it
so it's like me my dad my grandpa riding
around listen to Dave Ramsey you were
stuck with me you were stuck nothing
else to listen to oh the Captivity great
man that's the way to grow up right very
cool very cool how can we help today
kind of just looking for some
reassurance
um
so
we started a business
it was a hobby by the way we're in baby
steps four five and six
um we haven't put any money into six for
a while and I'm kind of looking for some
reassurance that we've done this right
we started a dairy a micro Dairy so it's
a little farm farming's my passion right
and I'm a real estate agent and I don't
have time to practice real estate now
because back in 2019 when we launched
our little hobby we made five thousand
dollars it's a great hobby it was fun
people thought it was a lot of fun so
2020 comes covet happens Pennsylvania
says no more real estate agents so I'm
like all right I'm gonna see where this
goes we made thirty thousand dollars
this isn't this is in gross sales we're
profit margins like 45 to 50 percent
and then in 2021 we're at 72 000 in
sales and this year we're probably going
to top out around 125 000 in sales
you know it's going amazingly well our
community loves it the surrounding
Community loves it we're putting on
events at other farms and our own Farm
we're selling this stuff out
everything's going great it's a passion
for me and my wife at this point
problem is I could make as much money
as a real estate agent in 40 hours as
it's taking me 80 to do it in this
and it's just like
are we being responsible with our time
at this point
you know we've been really responsible
with our money we've cash flowed this
thing and just and every time I make I
put back into this thing by the way
because my wife's a physician's
assistant she works 12-hour shifts at
the local hospital in Internal Medicine
so she makes twice as much money as I
ever will all the time
and we have three little kids 11 8 and 4
and
and we're just really busy
are we doing the right thing that's
that's my question
yes
you are thank you yes if you see a path
to uh get off the uh Rat wheel
you have to see it yet you have to see a
point that okay so like when we started
this I was working 16 hours a day I'd
come in at seven I was home at midnight
because I would do Financial Peace
University with an overhead projector at
night and for two years my wife was
basically a single mom
uh because we were starting this but we
saw a path that we were going to get
enough scale that I could we could hire
help we could find ways to produce
without me personally being the only one
producing in that point one of the
things we did was we put Financial Peace
University on VHS tapes that's a million
years ago right but I mean we found a
business model that allowed us to uh not
because I don't I'm not I don't want you
to sign up for 16 hours for 125 000 16
hour days for 15 years no I would not do
that
right but I think you've seen a growth
curve and a pattern here you probably
already have some ways to scale and if
you can get a little bit more scale and
start hiring into some of these other
positions delegate get your life back by
you you give up some of your margin to
payroll to have a life then uh you know
you're and it may be another year it may
be another 18 months before you're able
to do that maybe you I don't know where
the magic number is 175 000 Top Line I
don't know where it is but you've got to
see a path because what you're doing is
not sustainable it's working like no one
else but later I need to be able to work
like no one else
foreign
goals and say Here's here's what I want
it to be I want to hire two people we
have to make 200 Top Line I want to do
real estate this much on the side and
that means I need to be in the business
this much start setting some of those
goals instead of kind of it feels like
right now you're just kind of like oh
wow we made more than last year this is
cool we're doing so much time a
month-to-month thing here yeah we're
doing a month like every month it's like
okay we did this hey we won this month
we won that month and you know I I have
some distant goals you know like the the
I don't know who said this but somebody
said you know put your vision out there
in 10 years and build it backwards I
know what I want and I know what I want
in 10 years yeah but you haven't built
it back I just haven't built it
backwards right yeah right and what
George was talking about around here we
call it stage skating
that says okay we're not hiring a
developer and a digital marketer for
this product until it hits this amount
of Revenue but then when it hits this
amount of Revenue we can justify
Staffing into that particular project
but until but we're not going to hire
them and hope it works out
we're gonna build we're gonna gut it
we're gonna Sweat Equity at uh some of
the pull from some other teams poach off
of uh some other resources inside the
building legally
um and get to get the little thing up
off of the incubator and get it running
and when it hits X number of Revenue
then we'll staff into it and that's
called stage gating you know when you
hit a certain gate a certain stage you
open that gate and so that's what George
is talking about and that's a very very
good way for you to have some hope that
you're not stuck like a rat in a wheel
if you have that you should keep going
yeah yeah like I said this is our
passion neither one of us want to give
this up you are my wife yeah it's not
sustainable it's not sustainable yes
because she's she's cranking 35 40 hours
into this thing too on top of being Mom
and physician assistant yeah it's not
sustainable
you can't do this you can't do this for
a decade
so you I already told her I probably
can't do it for six more months you can
you could do it for another year if you
knew at the end of that year there was
relief but you can't do it where you
where there's no hope at the end
so there's a difference between being
tired and being burned out burned out is
there's no hope at the end tired as I'm
about to get there it's the same exact
feeling though
oh thank you yeah I am tired everybody
will say that yeah yeah I'm tired
listening to you I mean some of the
hardest working you ever do is dairy
that's a hard freaking work I had a
friend of mine grew up on a dairy and
she said her dad convinced them growing
up that Labor Day was the day you worked
the hardest
my dad told my dad told me one time he
said uh This Is The Life we've chosen
exactly and you can unchoose it but you
need to choose that there's that we're
not going to do this odd infinitum a
forever and ever amen this is not a song
it's your life
and so good really good question you're
a good man you're a hard worker you're
smart people your wife's a hard worker
she's a good woman you have a good
marriage you're setting goals you're
hitting them but you need a point where
you say at that point I get some relief
at that point I get some relief and I'll
give you another example when the book
Total Money Makeover came out uh we did
uh 47 days I was gone from home uh we
did like 22 Live Events something like
300 media hits uh something like 56 book
signings and uh when I got done I was
like almost in the hospital right I mean
from just sheer freaking exhaustion but
we knew it was going to end
and I thought my wife's at home with
three kids I'm on the road I'm done I
mean we're Total Money makeovers comes
out of the gate as a number one stays
number one we pushed it pushed it push
it to this day
you know uh almost 20 years later we're
still running off of some of the
momentum that that concentrated amount
of time kicked off right but that's not
sustainable it's not sustainable in our
marriage Sharon said I can do this for
47 days I can't do it for 68 days and
I'm not going to you're coming home and
I said I can do this for four I can I
can do another live event I can sign
another book if there's an end to it and
then we get to win because of the price
that was paid and so you you just you
got to dial up that thing of uh it's
almost like we were talking about a
while ago with the lady quitting her job
yeah or letting someone leave Ramsey in
Jesus name right I mean you know you
reach a point Henry Cloud talks about
necessary endings and there's his book
is called necessary endings in necessary
endings he says you have to end
something when there's no hope it's
going to get better
[Music]
and he's got plenty of hope he's going
to get better and Jesse I want to send
you a copy of Dave's best seller entree
leadership it's going to help you get
off this treadmill and grow and scale
this thing to where you want it to go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dave Ramsey
this hour and we are taking your calls
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five
thanks for joining us everybody Tracy is
next up in Lynchburg Virginia hi Tracy
how are you
oh Dave and um George I am so excited to
be here and only by the grace of God I
am better than I deserve good for you
how can we help okay so I had my I had
it moment back in August
um since then I've paid off fifteen
thousand dollars
um I am still seventy thousand dollars
in debt I make ninety thousand dollars
I'm 51 years old and I've been divorced
for a year and a half I work at a
company I've been with them for it was
it was an amicable split it was the best
thing for both of us and
um God has seen us both through so I'm
very grateful for having a good
relationship with him ending this but it
was what we needed to do so I worked for
a company I'm still working for a
company for 30 years back in 2009 they
froze their pension
and we got a notice back in September
that they are actually terminating the
pension which will take place next year
we don't get a benefits report until
March but I know that we have three
options that we have to make a decision
for in July one would be a lump sum
distribution the second is to roll it
over and the third is to start monthly
annuity payments at that time I have
Googled this so I am my eyeballs want to
pop out of my head there's only 4 000
answers on Google I'm sure I know and I
can I get a clear answer and
um I I know that I and I'm I'm certain
I'm sure there's going to be penalties
no there's not
zero penalties you're going to take the
lump sum and put it into an IRA get with
a smart investor Pro they'll help you do
the paperwork properly it's a direct
transfer rollover there's no penalties
there's no taxes and uh it will grow
from that point tax deferred you're
going to use a traditional IRA that way
there's no taxes if you roll it to a
Roth It's taxable but don't do that
um and don't okay that was another
question you don't want to make it
because it'll be taxable then
you make all of that income because it's
going to be a sizeable lump sum you've
been there a while
I've been there a while and I was there
17 years when they froze it yeah but I
mean you're gonna have it's going to be
it's gonna be 100 Grand plus and it
okay so you wouldn't you would not take
the lumps out no you don't get touched
it you're gonna get taxed and taxed and
penalties yeah no yeah text
at least taxed I'm not sure if they
close it if you're penalized I'm not
positive off the top of my head doesn't
matter you're not going to do that
you're going to do a traditional IRA
direct transfer rollover with your
smartvester pro in the four types of
mutual funds we talk about growth growth
and income aggressive growth and
international and by the way this is
great news it is I'm so excited I I've
listened to you forever and
um like I said a fire got lit under me
back in August and I'm like I make too
much money on my own
to be drowning like this and I'm taking
charge and when that came in the mail I
knew I knew it was the Lord saying this
is good news so I have a 401k at work
it's traditional one and I have three
hundred thousand dollars in there
currently do I put that in that one or
do I open a separate one no it's not you
cannot add it to a 401k that's not an
option you can uh okay yeah I would just
roll it to an IRA with a smartvester pro
you pick the mutual funds you're in
total control this money is leaving
this company and will have nothing to do
with them ever again when you die that
money is laying there in the meantime it
is earning more than it would have made
in the pension and so it's good news all
the way around but just just if you
don't have a smart investor Pro go to
ramseysolutions.com click on Smart
investor you can get a list of the
people in your area that are in our
smartvestor Pro program that do things
the way we teach and then you can meet
with them and choose among them the one
that best suits you
a lot of people call in with pension
questions Dave and if you have the
option let's say a listener is going I
started a new job they're giving me the
option of a pension or 401K we would say
go for the 401K because you have way
more control over it and it stays with
you usually uh and that's assuming that
they are putting something into the 401K
since they don't have to put something
into the pension if they give you that
option usually they're doing some kind
of really sweet match in the 401K and
the company would rather you go to the
401K it's better for both of you yeah
the company and them because the company
doesn't have to keep up and manage your
Investments your 401k is your own
investment so that's a good point George
very good point Ryan is in Baltimore hey
Ryan welcome to the Ramsay show
hi how you doing guys better than we
deserve what's up
so I got a couple questions for you um
my wife and I have been married for two
years and we will be out of Consumer
Debt and by the end of February
um we don't have a house we're currently
renting right now for my grandmother
um so once we're done paying off the
rest of our debt we'll obviously be
saving for a down payment of our house
once we're out of debt and we're done
throwing everything extra towards debt
we'll probably be making
five thousand dollars a month after our
monthly expenses
um so while we're doing that should we
be putting that five thousand roughly
into mutual funds or just putting it
into savings
um and right now we're also investing
what 500 a month into two retirement
accounts as well um 500 total 250 each
okay Ryan how long you been listening to
the show
um for
consistently about the last month and a
half I took Dave Ramsey's class in high
school
um when I was in school so I've been
kind of like on and off with Dave Ramsey
for a while now cool well you're you're
doing some good things you're just doing
them all at once and not in the right
order so if you're walking through the
baby steps you should be putting all of
your effort every single penny of margin
towards the debt which means we're not
investing currently and there was a spot
in between you said hey once we're debt
free we're gonna get the down payment
but you were missing the fully funded
emergency fund CDU currently have
savings for the for the emergency
so technically right now we do but
um I'm kind of not walking through the
baby steps originally like we've got
about 16 000 sitting in savings we're
actually going to pay off the car
totally we'll still have like two or
three thousand left after that
um sorry how much do you how much do you
have
it's about twenty six thousand
and what's in savings 16. 16 in savings
16. so if you took that down to one that
would leave you with 15 you could throw
with this debt
yep that's what we plan on doing
today
today yes yeah okay maybe step one's a
thousand baby step two is pay off all of
your debts once all of your debts are
paid off baby step three is build an
emergency fund so you go back to that
one thousand dollar account and you
raise it up to a fully funded emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
then you start saving for the down
payment on your home until then you
don't restart your retirement plan which
you stop today
okay because I want that 500 added to
that five thousand and make it six
thousand because you tighten up the
budget because I wanna and that means
you're debt free in two months and uh
then then you build your emergency fund
let's call that fifteen thousand and
three more months then you uh I'm making
that up but that's if that's what it is
and then in three more months you've got
it starting to have five four more
months you're starting to have a good
down payment this time next year you
start shopping for houses and you'll
have a good down payment with a fully
funded emergency fund and no debt and
you restart your retirement at that
point and the reason for all this is not
because we're trying to be legalistic
Ryan not because Dave said so but
because it actually freaking works when
you do it in this order with intensity
with focus and we've seen so many people
do it the right way and we've seen a lot
do it the wrong way and six months later
they're calling us saying your plan
didn't work and we're going oh you
didn't do our plan you did your plan did
your version of our plan such as not our
planet don't go don't do don't be Dave
ish which is what we call it go all in
on this stuff and I promise you going to
call us back and say I did it I paid off
all the debt we got her home now we have
a fully funded emergency fund we're
investing for the future man it gives
you such peace and confidence this just
has nothing to do with it being the
Ramsay way or ramsey-ish it has to do
with what is the fastest right way to
become wealthy what is the most
efficient use that moves you along the
process the fastest and the easiest and
that's what this system is and we've
used it for so many years that we've
proven that that's the case and so you
know total focus on baby steps one two
three till you get there then do your
down payment then restart your emergency
fund and you'll be in a really good
shape so well done well done this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where debt is done cash is
King in the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships George
Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Kathy is in Reno starting off this hour
hi Kathy how are you
hi good how are you better than we
deserve what's up
yes I had I had a hospital bill that has
gone into collections
uh just over a thousand dollars but have
interest so it's really eleven hundred
dollars
uh I have made them offers which they
have rejected my last offer was five
hundred dollars and now they're saying
they will not uh take any offers or
negotiations only uh paid in full uh so
I just need help navigating this and
also I want to know if it's legal for
them to charge interest on medical debt
sure it's perfectly legal
okay why do you not have a thousand
dollars
um
what would it take for you to get a
thousand dollars in the next 30 days
what would you have to do
uh I really am not sure uh my situation
is a little different so
um
are you working currently
uh so uh sort of I am a missionary
you're a what say again
Mary oh okay all right
so is income provided to you through
donors uh the ministry
yes
so how much do you make a month
about uh two thousand
okay and you're so you're trying to
provide housing and eat and do your
mission work
yes
okay
um
do I I don't know I mean there's a lot
of different uh
uh things that take the form of mission
okay
um
uh and so I don't know what
constrictions there are on your time uh
constraints there are on your time but
if there's any way you could work three
nights a week you can find a thousand
dollars pretty quick and make this
problem go away
you're trying to you're trying to nickel
and dime a very small problem it's not a
small problem in your world because you
don't have a lot of money coming in you
don't have any money but
um but it might as well be ten thousand
dollars emotionally right but the best
yes that's the bad news the good news is
it really is only a thousand dollars and
and not to minimize the pain that you're
feeling or the stress or the frustration
you're feeling with this but uh but
sitting back here I mean uh do you have
a car
uh no
okay not that's ours no what do you mean
did you did you say not that size
no we we have one but we borrow it it's
not our car okay are you allowed to use
it to say deliver food
so you could work with the car three
nights a week doing Uber each as an
example
uh sure yes okay uh how how many nights
could you do that
six seven
um maybe two two okay all right and as
many hours as you can possibly work on
those two nights the more the better and
the quicker you do get rid of this the
quicker you don't have to do that
anymore agreed
yes yes yeah and so um
yeah uh uh what type of mission
organization are you with
uh well we're I don't really want to say
too much but um we're worldwide
and we do pretty much everything under
the sun okay but mostly humanitarian
okay that's fine that's fine I'm just
trying to figure out what the I mean
we've worked with a lot of Evangelical
Christian situations LDS does a two-year
plan uh you know there's all kinds of
Christian I'm sorry Christian okay it's
a Christian organization okay all right
I mean like we used with a mission we've
done a lot of stuff with those folks and
uh those are usually uh shorter stints
uh you uh Young Life a lot of those
folks work on support so we you know
we've interacted with a whole bunch of
people in your situation that's why I'm
trying to you know figure out a way to
be helpful here so oh yes again the bad
news is the um that you've got all this
mess and this pressure and these people
are calling and they're nasty when they
call and they cut they make you feel
like a dog and you're not
um you're just a person with a medical
bill okay but the faster you can scrape
together a thousand dollars working like
a crazy person the faster this goes away
and I would want you to do that in two
or three weeks what do you think George
yeah okay Kathy do you have any other
debt
no this is it the thousand dollars yes
and how much money do you have in the
bank
uh right now nothing zero dollars
okay yes okay and what was the uh the
the what happened what was the medical
event
I just arrived to the United States
um
I it was something with my stomach
were you working with that mission
organization at that time
yes okay I I again I don't know how the
uh structure is of your organization and
that will matter so this this in other
words this suggestion may be stupid is
what I'm saying but it's possible with
some Mission organizations that you were
under their care at that time and I
would submit this to your supervisor uh
whoever's leading the mission in your
area and say hey this happened while I
was on the mission field with you guys
can you help me with it and just as a
one-time instead of two thousand dollars
this month I need three thousand and you
don't even have to send it to me you can
send it direct to the hospital and see
if they'll help you cover that because
you were uh you know you're in there
you're part of their organization you're
part of their family so I would ask
about that if you think that's
appropriate I don't know but it wouldn't
be unusual for
a lot of mission organizations to go oh
yeah we can do that we'll help you with
that it's not again it's not a hundred
thousand dollars it's a thousand dollars
uh it was a trip to Quick Trip to the
emergency room you were overcharged for
it because we always are when we go to
the emergency room and uh it's always
horrible service and it's
low expectations yeah really and and you
know so sorry if you work in the ER
sorry about that but I mean most of us
dread the idea of spending seven hours
waiting in there for yourself it's 90
for an Advil and so that also frustrates
you yeah that's true that's a tough
situation remember Walgreens and got
that yeah CVS has got a deal on them
this week with a coupon yeah anyway yeah
so I I'm trying to help but I I think
creating this very very quickly instead
of trying to figure out a way to make
the hospital behave instead let's just
pay them
and that's what I'm having to get the
monkey off your back yeah because the
great news is you're 100 debt free free
to serve God when you get this monkey
off your back this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're so glad you're here Hey
listen if you love this show there's
three things you can do to help us
pay us back because you get to listen
for free you get the advice for free and
I know some of you think that's what
it's worth I got that haha it's funny
okay but the uh the truth is that uh if
you want to pay us back the way you do
that is help us you subscribe to the
show so if you're a YouTuber or a
podcaster or whatever you just hit
subscribe that helps us it helps spread
the word among those platforms that this
show is popular uh you can share the
show that means like if you listen on
talk radio thank you for that just tell
people the station you listen to but uh
if you you want to click the link and
send it out on you know Spotify or apple
or YouTube or whatever you can do that
we would love to have you do that and of
course where you're able to leave us a
five-star review uh one star reviews are
not helpful mom always said if you
didn't have something nice to say don't
say nothing so there you go that was
before social media day well I know but
times have changed it's uh now they have
comment sections dedicated to hate
I know I'm aware of that and that's what
I'm trying to prevent so that's helpful
I'm learning uh our question today comes
from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free you got free samples free shipping
with the two new promos that run all the
time you can save even more always use
the promo code the best deal anywhere
click Ramsay
today's question lions.com go ahead yeah
our today's question comes from Janet in
Rhode Island she asks my husband and I
we're 65 years old we're traveling
nurses and we are paid we have paid
housing stipends we're debt free we own
a house worth 750 000 in the country on
five acres of land next to our daughter
and her family we've got 800 000 in the
retirement accounts and 200 000 in cash
my son just left the ministry and
therefore has no savings and owns no
real estate he's renting our house and
wants to buy it he's got five kids and
it's a five bedroom house which is too
much for my husband and I how do we sell
the house to him we wanted to sell it to
him on contract and he would have to get
a loan and pay the estate for what is
left if we die the property's in a trust
now and we only spend the summers in
Iowa where the house is located and
we'll retire there someday but we want a
smaller house we plan on building a
small thousand dollar square foot house
on the property when the prices come
down love listening to your show
signed Janet very cool well they've done
very well yeah got a net worth of almost
two million dollars it looks like yep
um well I I would not have
uh
payments owed on the house if you want
to
uh keep him from
uh let's get so convoluted
um
so what would I do
uh I don't believe in having debt with
anyone but for sure not with family
so what can we do we could give him the
house
that's possible uh check out the unified
estate tax credit you use up part of
your federal estate tax exemption to
avoid gift tax if you don't do this
properly you're gonna get your butt
taxed off over 300 Grand in taxes so you
need to see a Tax Advisor a tax attorney
an estate planning attorney and get this
done properly it's worth the money you
would spend with them the unified estate
tax credit so I would give them the
house if you want to
uh and then reduce their you know his
portion of the inheritance by the value
of the house at the time you give it to
him
um
if you want to
further control it it's in a trust you
could
um
give him the house with a lean filed
against the house
with no payments and no interest
uh and that that lien is Forgiven at
death
yeah it's just it it guarantees that his
portion of the estate
goes to this house in other words
because here's what could happen Okay
let's say you just give it to him uh he
could go uh
get a divorce
and uh not likely I mean former Pastor
hopefully that's not going to happen but
it's happened before and
um then half of the value of that house
would have to go to her and he wouldn't
get a mortgage for 375 000 to pay her
out um
uh because those are marital assets
maybe maybe not because there's a gift
from Mom but who knows I mean I stranger
things have happened in divorce court
that were not just
um
Justice isn't always served in our court
system
um the um
so yeah I mean that would kind of keep
crap like that from happening or he
could just kind of lose his mind and
forget to be grateful and decide he
doesn't want to talk to anybody in the
family and he's already got your money
and all that uh and then he wants to go
run up and borrow uh 600 000 mortgage
and go buy Six sports cars in a uh in a
boat you know or whatever and uh now
he's leveraged up this house this next
door to your next door to his sister
your daughter in the next door to you
where you want to build your 1 000
square foot retirement place and all
that so yeah I'm probably putting a lien
on it
that's the cleanest way that is
forgiving that is Forgiven out of the
estate and no payments and no interest
until then because he can't afford this
thing if they sell it to him he can't
pay payments on this he can't well we
don't think we don't know what his
income is well he hasn't got any money
he's got no savings coming out of
ministry we don't know what his new job
is and right but he's not in a place to
buy an 800 000 house tomorrow it sounds
unless you got a job making a million
dollars a year I don't know what he's
doing yeah but I I would probably just
give it to him with a lien on it that's
forgiven in the estate and who's the
right team you would have in place state
tax estate planning attorney could do
every bit of it okay and they can help
you with the unified estate tax you can
deal with the fact that it's in a trust
you can deal with every bit of it on how
to structure it but I would do something
along those lines because of the things
I just outlined yeah I don't want
payments
I don't want Thanksgiving dinner to
taste different because the borrower is
slave to the lender and you don't get
away with that
Christmas dinner in this case tastes
different right but um and you need to
talk this through with his sibling your
daughter lives next door if I understood
that right is that what she said yeah
yeah yeah yeah next door to our daughter
and her family and say okay you're
getting yours on our death and it will
have grown more than his his will grow
as he owns it yours is in Investments
and it will grow because she's got 800
000 over here yeah right and so you'll
get
he's gotten some of his half if not most
of his half if not all of his half
and um just let her know everybody needs
to know everything and it all needs to
be done in a business-like methodology
in writing and you need to understand
what the downsides of all of it is
what's the worst thing that could happen
in some bizarre scenario and be willing
to accept that scenario before you go
forward that's that's part of managing
wealth is stewarding it well and knowing
here's what's going to happen to it
after I'm gone absolutely skip is in
Saint Petersburg Florida hi Skip how are
you
I'm I'm well Dave and thank you for
taking my call Merry Christmas to you
and all your staff Merry Christmas how
can we help
I have a question for you
um my wife is 60 7 I'm 74. we have been
extraordinarily blessed in our personal
lives and in my business life
we currently own
two homes our primary residence is in
Saint Pete
with a 350 000 remaining mortgage
with an interest rate of 2.8 percent
I have another small home in North
Carolina
with a remaining mortgage of a hundred
and twenty five thousand dollars at
three percent
uh the home in St Petersburg Florida is
probably worth about seven hundred
thousand
a home in North Carolina is probably
Worth close to four
uh I have we have
uh 1.5 million in a Roth IRA
and another million dollars in a
traditional IRA
I'm not sure I just don't
think it's a wise move today to pay
those mortgages off even though I could
okay what's your question
what do you think I should do probably
got to pay them off by the end of the
day
you want to know why even
yes neither neither one of these answers
yours or mine is going to cause you to
be blessed financially or to be bankrupt
your did a great job skip you're gonna
be okay either way
you're gonna sleep different you're
going to walk different you're going to
sit in the chair different when you
don't have a mortgage this is why you've
worked so hard
to put all this money away so you can
have some peace and you can enjoy this
money and if you hate it they'll get you
another mortgage after you're debt free
but you won't hate it
you won't hate it at all the borrower's
slave to the lender and when you're free
you're going to be free indeed
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five couple
of upcoming hours here on the Ramsey
Show and we want you to sign up to be a
part of them
coming up on December the 14th of next
week we'll be doing
our annual giving show so if you have a
great story of generosity
you were on the receiving end of
generosity or on the giving end of
generosity and it's inspiring to other
people because we want to inspire people
to outrageous generosity with the show
then uh you can email us at our email
address ask
ramseysolutions.com ask
ramseysolutions.com also we're planning
to do a couple of uh upcoming entree
leadership theme hours where we're going
to be taking calls from small business
people with business questions so any
kind of business question that you might
have we can schedule you to be a part of
that hour as well problem you've got
something you want solved that kind of
thing again for the entree leadership
theme hour use the same email address
just put instead of giving in the
subject line put entree leadership in
the subject line or business hour or
whatever you want to say ask at
ramseysolutions.com is the email address
ask at
ramsaysolutions.com Michael is in the
Netherlands hey Michael welcome to the
Ramsay show
hello sir thank you for taking my call
sure what's happening at you two are uh
better than you deserve I am uh an
active duty military member stationed in
the Netherlands my wife Margaret is
leaving GS employment and moving to a
location where she won't be working
we're currently in baby steps four five
and six contributing 15 to our 401K
should we open an IRA in her name or
keep contributing to the account that is
in my name
doesn't matter
uh if you want to open IRAs in both of
your names you can
in the event of a divorce in any state
in the U.S retirement accounts are joint
assets and will be divided
in the event of day in the event of
death you would leave all of yours to
her she would leave all of hers to you
so it doesn't really matter whose name
it's in
perfect well I really appreciate your
time and uh wishing you all a merry
Christmas you too thanks for your
service Michael
thank you so that's an interesting thing
to think about George so really what you
keep in mind we say it baby step four or
15 of your income going into retirement
right yes and uh the funny question we
get is is it 15 of my income or her
income or both I'm going well 15 of both
of your incomes individually is 15
collectively yeah so that's a good
that's how that math thing works that's
a baseline uh question just answered
right there that still comes up a lot
but so the thing is if her 401K has
great options a great match in his Roth
and you don't have a 401k well let's
load hers up
and just name you as the beneficiary in
the event of her death and if the
marriage goes sideways you'll split her
401K that's how it works so um
you know it's not a it's not a uh a
rights issue or you know uh ladies
aren't protected because all the assets
are in the husband's name it's not the
case just doesn't work that way or vice
versa for that matter gentleman's not
protected because Saul and his wife's
name doesn't not that's not the way it
works a little tough to lie about
retirement accounts in the court system
so um that that's what you're facing so
yeah you can you can put the Roth IRAs
in both or either names and sometimes
you just do it for the fun of it I mean
like uh you know we've got a mutual fund
Sharon's dad many many many many moons
ago send us a check
it's in each of his kids a check not a
huge one but a but more than we were
used to seeing and she's like I want to
put that in a mutual fund well we did
and it got her name on it and it's got
my name on it but it's Sharon's mutual
fund you know if you want to ask her
she'll say it's her she'll tell you you
know and so my point is it's just it's
kind of humorous in that sense but uh uh
you know and that was 20 plus years ago
so that's definitely a marital asset now
with that amount of time having passed
and uh certainly the growth on it is
well exceeded the uh actual original
amount going in but anyway all that to
say if that was a Roth IRA and it was in
her name in mutual funds fine I'm the
beneficiary in the event of death we
have the same co-beneficiaries if both
of us die secondary beneficiaries and um
again if there's a marriage problem and
there's a split then you should split
them all up just add them all up and
split it down the middle and so
the point being is do what accounts are
the best which ones are going to give
you the best
torture goal of retiring wealthy and
regardless of whose name they go in so
match beats Roth beats traditional so if
you've got a match with one of the
spouses let's go with that and let's
fill up the Roth accounts and then move
to the traditional as the last one it's
good absolutely Madeleine's in Detroit
hi Madeline how are you
good how are you today better than we
deserve how can we help
yeah so I was calling um because me and
my husband recently just read baby steps
basically last month
um with that we're now to step two and
in doing that we my husband had a Tesla
lease and getting out of that cost us
about nine grand but however that's gone
now we're working towards our debt of
student loans we have about 33 000 with
that however with that now we're down to
one car the car was given by my family
to me
um just to use in the meantime so we
have a car there's an indefinite time on
it but just wondering at what point
should we look to either buy a used
cheaper car for a second car if that's
after we pay off the student loans which
were asked me in about five months or if
that before we start building up the
emergency fund we're just trying to get
answers on when the best time would be
to look at that and you need a second
card today it sounds like you guys are
saying you can get by for a while
without it is this is The Loner is The
Loner or the second car or your main car
I'm The Loner so we got rid of the lease
the Tesla's gone we're just down to the
one car that's alone for my family
basically okay so you don't even own a
car
no oh okay what's your name anymore now
that we got rid of it um annually we're
at 220
000.
and and uh so this loan to you is it
okay if you keep it three months
yes okay
all right uh I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
driving that one then
um
or
okay what would I do if I were in your
shoes making 200 000 freaking dollars a
year and you just got rid of a Tesla
you're 9k in the hole on crap
uh
if you would be willing to drive as your
second car a five or six thousand dollar
car
I would go buy one now
if you're unwilling to drive that and
you want to wait a little bit and get a
20 000 car that you pay cash for then
just drive the loaner but I'd keep the
loaner and go get a six thousand dollar
car if I made 200 000 a year I'd be a
two-car family with a six thousand
dollar paid for a car and a loaner
that's that's just getting out of the
ditch no pun intended
do you guys have savings right now
yeah so we have once this Tesla has paid
off which will go out Friday we'll be
down to about twenty four thousand
um so with that gonna put that towards
the debt of course
um we're just waiting for of course the
Tesla final payment to come through that
we're gonna get rid of so really you
guys could be debt free next month no I
got thirty thousand dollars of student
loan debt but they have 24 in in cash so
you're saying you're going to apply that
towards the 33 of student loans minus
nine yeah
oh you haven't you're not out of the
hole yet with the Tesla you got to pay
the nine out of that 24 right
nope that's the nines out of the 24
already completely out
take all the savings which we're gonna
towards it why does it take two months
to come up with six thousand dollars if
you make 200 a year
so we have that six thousand like we
have that going out of our savings like
we have it budgeted to have six grand at
the end of this month to go towards that
which means you'll be debt free
24 and 6 is 30.
you have 30 000 students four grand left
33 000. 33. oh okay all right yeah
semantics either way you're debt free in
a month or two three in a month month
and a half two months and you're buying
and you're saving for a car I would just
drive that car if you want to go get a
six thousand dollar car and drag it out
one more month that's fine too but
you're gonna turn around and trade that
car in three months anyway so it's just
a get by car if you do that any of that
is fine don't go buy a 25 000 car though
until you pay cash for it and you're
debt free drive like no one else this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys put down the Christmas
cookies and get to ramseysolutions.com
right now you'll save calories
uh yeah you got three days left to get
everything in by Christmas with free
shipping on orders over forty dollars
last minute shopping uh doesn't mean you
have to settle for less meaningful gifts
the 2023 Ramsey gold planner is still
here I cannot believe those are not gone
they're almost sold out I keep thinking
they're going to be gone any minute they
may be gone but this copy as soon as you
said it yeah so well the copy might be
old you never know but uh just in time
we've also got the uh Christmas Version
the limited edition Rachel Cruz wallet
in red for the Holidays full grain hand
sewn wallet with a built-in cash
envelope system now comes in a beautiful
shade of red just for Christmas
new Ramsay apparel t-shirts crew necks
and hoodies with some of your favorite
uh Ramsay sayings like better than I
deserve
ramseysolutions.com get your gifts and
remember free shipping uh from now uh
you can get it in time for Christmas
still on orders over forty dollars
ramsaysolutions.com Bonnie is with us
Bonnie is in Rockford Illinois hi Bonnie
how are you
better than I deserve days good how can
I help
uh my employer is moving our 401K from a
local Financial Service to Fidelity
um my financial planner suggests that
now is the time that I could move that
money over into a self-directed IRA
I'd have a many more investment options
that way
self-directed but just an IRA in your
name
right okay there's a difference you
don't want you don't want to
self-directed you don't need that but
just do it roll over because with the
change of companies you're allowed to
roll your 401k over yeah I would do that
is your 401k currently a Roth
um it's probably mostly 401K I did
change no I mean you can have a 401K
Roth
the the company only offered 401K in the
beginning and then after say 10 years or
so in a day 20 years and then they
started offering Roth and you switched
to Roth so you got you got some of each
and then I also have profit sharing so
you have some Roth and some traditional
in your current 401K that you're going
to roll
yeah and also profit sharing okay do you
have a mortgage
okay then you just roll your Roth
portion to Roth
and you roll your traditional portion to
traditional to create no taxes in the
rollover
so you'd have two IRAs
okay so still keep them separate yes
because if you if you move the
traditional to Roth when you do the
rollover you're going to be taxed on all
of that and you don't need to pay taxes
while you still got a mortgage
okay and then there's also a profit
sharing in there that they're going to
let us manage now
manage or leave with you can roll it too
uh I'll double check but that's also
that was the new thing was going with
Fidelity we'll be able to manage our
profit sharing portion and manage might
be that you choose the Fidelity Fund to
put it in
yeah that we can choose the funds yeah
but not be able to move it to your
smartvester pro
yeah they I don't know what they mean by
manage
if they mean by manage see with your old
401K what they mean by managers you're
taking it
it's no longer going to be anywhere near
them you're going to have it in an IRA
it's gone you totally are managing it
follow me
yes yeah and if they mean that with a
profit sharing that's different than oh
you get to select your funds with
Fidelity and we'll call that you
managing it neither one are super bad
because Fidelity's got some good funds
you can pick that one for your profit
sharing portion but I'd roll the other
two portions I agree with your financial
planner but roll the Roth portion to a
Roth the traditional to a traditional so
you don't have any taxes now the profit
sharing Dave I haven't heard of one that
is part of retirement it's not so is
this just a cash account probably okay
it's probably uh it could be in a tax
protected thing depending on how they've
structured it
but most likely it's not most likely
it's just a simple account that's over
there that they have to wait you have to
wait till you're vested
before you would own that account in the
event of you leaving that company makes
sense
all right San Antonio is next Becky's on
the line hi Becky welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi Dave how are you
we deserve how can we help
I would like to quit my job and I'm
trying to decide if it's a good idea at
this point
can you eat if you quit your job
yes we can definitely eat we do still
have one kid to get through college and
um it's and but I'd like to have more
time to take care of Aging parents and
spend more time with kids get ready for
a wedding that's coming up and so um
what do you make I just
I make 125. what's he make
250. okay
well I think you can struggle through on
250.
I think we can but it's it's I mean it's
um it's going to be a different life for
sure somewhere used to yeah you gotta
pay attention but guess what you had to
pay attention all along hadn't you
yeah we have did y'all didn't start out
making 375 household
no no and I guess my
my retirement paid for it just for the
next you know you know to eight years
before we get to retirement if we can if
you can squeakers yes well okay the way
you say it it's something it's
rhetorical now Becky do you guys have
any debt
uh we that's one of the big we do still
have a mortgage
um so and that was kind of my question
like do I tough it out till we get
through paying off the mortgage how much
is a mortgage I'd rather right now we
have about 250 left on it okay we'll
tough it out would be what two years
yeah if we cut back significantly which
we can't we've already started
we're getting ready to cut 125 000 out
of your budget when you quit so you
ought to be able to throw 125 000 at the
mortgage times two is 250.
so the cutback significantly is what
you're getting ready to do
right
yeah
you understand I do yes I do I'm just
messing with your math to make sure
you're doing your math well your
homework is to go look at your budget
and say if we cut out this income
entirely what would have to change and
go through from the top priority which
is your four walls food utilities
housing Transportation go down the list
and you might need to cut some of the
luxuries you've been enjoying the last
few years but you might not think when
you do that exercise with your husband
the two of you sitting I think you
actually do the math it makes you step
back from the emotions what you're
probably going to discover is is that
you're going to pay off the mortgage
three or four years slower if you quit
yeah
okay and you're and you're what 56 how
old are you no I'm 51. oh okay
so by the time you're 56 how old is he
he's 50. okay well let's lay out a game
plan to pay off the mortgage if you work
that's two years if you quit work
four years
yeah layout of game plan or five years
or six years I don't care but lay out a
game plan and look at the math and go
that's what then we gotta that means
that that vacation we're not doing that
purchase over there that we were you
know we're gonna have to actually pay a
little more attention to the clothing
and the eating out because it's freaking
gotten out of control or whatever it is
okay but to George's Point look at the
actual budget and say this is how we're
going to live if I quit but can you
afford to quit yes are you willing to
make the trade-offs that you quitting is
going to require probably when you look
at them you probably are
yeah I think you're going to quit
yeah and worst case you can go get
another job right
oh absolutely absolutely and I that's
what I'd love to do is do something that
just isn't as demanding for sure yeah
well there's that it's not irreversible
I mean you could take like a year off
and then if you wanted to say I'm gonna
go do this cool thing and kick butt for
uh 18 months and finish this mortgage
off and then quit again
you're just a quitter
I like it I think it's a great plan but
what you want to do is you want to look
at the hardcore reality with the math
and say this is the trade-off and I
think you can do it and I think you
probably should do it based on just your
conversation I think you've been very
responsible you all have done a
wonderful job with your money you make a
lot of money you put yourself in this
position congratulations touchdown this
is the Ramsay shadow
foreign
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey Show we're dead as Dom cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
it is a free call here and some say the
advice is worth what you pay for it
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
Vermont is on the line Janet is with us
hi Janet how are you
I'm good how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
uh I'm calling about a previous episode
I need a little clarification on there
was a woman that had called in and child
had uh basically disowned them and they
were conflicted on the will and taking
them out and you mentioned it as kind of
a grieving
um period for the loss that a parent
seals which makes sense but you've also
in the past said if you're not leaving a
child something in the will then
um you need to be the the bigger person
and say you know what you're out uh how
do you do that if they're not speaking
to you um I wouldn't do that if they're
not speaking to you the one I've said
that in the past it wasn't a universal
blanket every single time you tell
someone but if someone is misbehaving
and you're communicating with them or
they're not you know behaving in a way
that is honoring to you your values your
family and so you're not going to leave
them in an example would be
um I mean you got a kid doing heroin but
you're trying to love them and you're
still talking to them I'm going to tell
them I'm not leaving you money for
heroin
because I love you
right and you need to know that you're
not going to be in there but a kid who
won't speak to me
uh I don't having you know you don't
need to a person who won't speak to you
you don't need to let them know that
they're not in the will like in other
words Janet I'll talk to you so I'm not
but prior to the day I've never talked
to you and if I wasn't in your will you
didn't need to let me know
right right and that makes sense but
like to not leave a bunch of stress for
the other child that's involved would
you then suggest like a letter with the
lawyer yeah yeah I'd leave a letter with
them and just go you know if you want to
be mad at somebody be mad at me but you
decided you didn't want a relationship
with me which means you don't want a
relationship with anything to do with me
and so I I hate that and I'm sad about
that and I've been sad about that since
it happened but uh as a result I didn't
we didn't feel like it was a proper to
leave money to someone that hates us
okay that's fair uh one more thing
George told me to call in so I wanted to
say thanks to him for that and he does
not have a punchable face thank you that
was just another day a punchable face I
said that on air when we were commenting
about my viral Tick Tock and I said I
think they just hate me I've got a
punchable face they come for me in the
comments and so she's just because I
never said you had a punchable face Dave
would never no but I'm just saying I was
telling him I might have punched you but
I wouldn't have said anything about it
well and I was just telling him that
that's them projecting what they don't
like about themselves
you're exactly right welcome to
understand that welcome to tick tock
commenters you've got the psychology
down Janet
so yeah it's a it's a it's an
interesting nuance and a good question
thank you for calling in
you know and the Beautiful part about uh
the holidays is we get to see and deal
with family the horrible part about the
holidays is we get to see see and deal
with family
um so in some cases and so uh that
brings up a lot of these
estate questions and I think it's a good
thing to talk about
um
if someone else says it out loud it
doesn't sound as crazy as maybe or as
shame inducing as it sounds in your head
so
um you know the way we stand on things
around here you and I have talked about
this many times George and and uh is
that uh you are under no moral legal or
ethical obligation to leave anyone your
money
period That's a good one to start with
okay and you are under no
uh you have no moral entitlement
to Mama's money
that is the underlying issue yeah
because they're scared of what are the
kids going to think and is it going to
cause resentment and will the
relationships be hurt
and uh you know hopefully you don't
raise entitled kids which luckily you
didn't Dave and so but I mean like the
lady they called the other day her
daughter will no longer speak to her uh
over an argument they had during covid
that she wanted to come visit and give
her a hug and she said not in my house
you can't touch us you don't you're
coming to kill us and so you know crazy
coveted people right and so they they
refuse to let the mom and dad come and
refuse to let them see their grandkids
and then it escalated further and just
don't even call we don't want to talk to
you and it's been since covered they
haven't spoken and so she said do I
leave her in the will and I said I
wouldn't no no you have no she has no
rights and you have no obligation
um and it's not about you hitting back
I'm angry at you so I'm taking you out
of the will it's not about manipulating
because we're not really going to call
her and discuss it with her we're not
trying to manipulate anybody it's a
matter of God gave me this batch of
money to manage I manage it for him
so what does the owner
require of this it requires no first and
foremost that I leave it to someone else
who will also manage it for him that's
wisdom first and foremost
so if you decide uh you know like we're
Christians at our house and so as for me
and my house that's who we are and so if
you decide that you're going to worship
a tree or whatever it is you're going to
worship
um and not worship God then
I represent him I manage stuff for him
and why would I leave a tree worshiper
God's stuff
I'm not going to do that
I don't dislike trees but I don't
worship them and so I never thought I'd
hear that sentence on the show yeah
there you go here we are you have to
have to have lots of clarity for the
tree people but the uh um you know so
the but the point is it would be
inconsistent with your values
and what your beliefs are
and so don't ask don't be obligated by
bloodline only to do something that
otherwise sounds crazy because it is
crazy that's why it sounds crazy it's
something to remember something sounds
crazy it's because it's crazy it is it's
like the old thing uh uh you know a guy
used to work here would say you say you
know if you're dating a girl and she
says I'm not crazy that's a sure sign
that she's crazy right that's a red flag
that's a red flag right there you know
that one's crazy and so if something
sounds crazy it's usually because it is
if it feels crazy it's usually because
it is if it feels weird and awkward and
not right it's usually because it's
weird awkward not listen to that voice
yeah and so you know I don't want to
leave money to a kid who won't speak to
me because she's pissed about me wanting
to give her a hug during covet well that
Perfectly Natural but I feel bad why do
you feel bad
I you know I don't feel bad at all I
don't leave strangers and people that
don't talk to me and people that are mad
at me I don't pick out trolls on Twitter
and leave them money that would be a
strange people that have people that
hate me why would I people that don't
want to talk to me people that are mad
at me people that dislike me people that
disrespect me why would I leave them
money that doesn't make any sense at all
and so give yourself a pass give
yourself a get out of jail free card on
the guilt shame and request the baggage
that goes with inheritance during the
holidays this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is
our co-host today Thomas is with us in
New York City Welcome to the Ramsey Show
Hey Thomas Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas to you too Dave thank
you so much hello gentlemen how you
doing great man what's up nothing quick
question first of all I just wanted to
preface it by saying Dave I've been
listening your show for a while and I
really want to thank you for every all
your advice I used to be one of those
people that really just thought about
well yeah I can afford that payment I
you know I can afford that payment and
just all of a sudden I'm just under this
massive amount of debt and after
listening to for a couple months I just
basically restructured the way I do
everything I'm just you know stop buying
stuff I'm getting my debts paid off I'm
within a couple years I plan to be
completely debt free so thank you very
much for your your advice um my question
my question is I've heard you talk a
little bit about Whole Life policies now
my wife and I right now have Whole Life
policies they're good until we're 125
years old we have about 1.5 million
dollars in coverage cost us about 680 a
month to have that
um and I've heard you sort of say that
you didn't think they were a great
investment but I haven't really heard
you get into any details about why you
think that is so I was wondering if you
could just talk about that a little bit
and and you know maybe maybe I'm missing
something and if if I am I'm sure you'll
you'll hit the point okay sure
um well the the overarching
main companies that sell whole life the
numbers break down about like this
per hundred dollars that you pay in
premium
you can buy the same amount of term life
insurance 15-year level term 20-year
level term for about five dollars
it it's roughly 20 x
okay and uh for the insurance
obviously whole life though has another
component to it the term does not have
you're obviously aware of that you spend
a lot of money on this and that other
component is a cash value build up
now the cash value build up is the other
ninety five dollars out of a hundred
dollars approximately could be 91
dollars could be whatever but it's
somewhere in that range nationally
across the top 10 like whole life
insurance companies it is 95 okay so
ninety five dollars going into cash
value five dollars purchases the same
amount of insurance life insurance now
so then the the gripe that those of us
have that hate whole life life insurance
and it's not a mild dislike I hate it
um is that uh is that what happens to
that ninety five dollars
and uh in cash value what you will do
and you're well past this but if you
went back and looked at your policy
Pages your cash value build up for the
first three years your savings build up
is zero one hundred percent of the
ninety five dollars goes to fees it's
front loaded as an investment which in
and of itself is not necessarily evil
it's just frowned upon in the financial
planning World by and large
um
the second thing is that once you do
start building it nationally and again
don't know your policy but it's not
going to be substantially different uh
the average rate of return on the ninety
five dollars if you look at your actual
cash value build up including the three
years of zeros on the front end it ends
up being an average of about 1.2 percent
let's be generous and say it's double
that 2.4 still not a good long-term
investment if I could get 2.4 on my
money market I'd be dancing a jig but uh
but not on my long-term Investments my
long-term Investments need to be north
of 10 to be beating inflation and taxes
and so it's a horrible rate of return on
a long-term investment and those two
things are bad but the the the stake in
the heart of whole life and the reason
the entire financial planning community
that are not in the whole life life
insurance business have abandoned whole
life no one sells this but whole life
insurance agents no one sells it anymore
no traditional financial planner no
smart investor Pro no one in the
financial World sells it the only people
that sell it or whole life agents
they've gone away from it and and this
is the reason once you've paid the extra
95 dollars to build up build up build up
build up and uh on your 680 dollar
premium you you said you had a one point
something million dollar policy one I've
got a million dollars my wife has half a
million and that's our combined premium
interesting okay so 1.5 million
if you die your wife the beneficiary I
assume would get one million dollars
that's your face
my daughter it doesn't matter yes yeah
whoever the beneficiaries is going to
get the million dollars right that's
what they're going to get
that's all
right if you have a cash value of 200
000 at 2.4 percent that you put 95
dollars per hundred in to get to 200 000
or to get to a hundred thousand none of
that so you have a savings account that
for the first three years you put in
there gives you nothing after that it
pays 2.4 percent and when you die they
keep your money
all right which makes it absolutely
horrendous so you're much better off in
many many decades ago the financial
planning Community by and large started
moving towards buying term life
insurance for the five dollars per
hundred and doing almost anything else
with the 95 but over in the investment
world away from the insurance world
put it in a freaking fruit jar at least
it's there when you die
okay so you said would you would your
advice be to just terminate those
policies and just put and do what you
suggested purchase relatively
inexpensive term Life policies and then
put you know additional money I mean I I
do have Investments I mean I could just
up those Investments I invest into the
direct mostly directly in the S P 500
I've got a 401k exactly but get the term
life in place first yeah exactly get
your term in place first never cancel
life insurance until you've got new in
place because we don't want you to have
the proverbial milk truck or bus in the
middle okay between the two just look at
the money I've been spending over the
last five ten years is just write that
off and just start it'll make you want
to throw up yeah yes but that's that's
okay you will get you will get your cash
value out by canceling the policies
whatever it is okay that doesn't it
doesn't uh it does not then but you
never get both
I understand you never get the insurance
and the Investments and you're always
paying for both and that's the got it
that's the consumer Advocate like us our
reason for hating on these things and
just saying they're absolutely horrible
it's an Antiquated product from the 40s
and 50s that built large buildings in
the skylines of almost every city and uh
and that everyone now has pretty well
moved away from except the companies
with their name on that kind of stuff so
uh anyway okay all of that to say one
last cat one last part of this
discussion that's worth having because
you're you're obviously doing well
financially and you're you're doing
really good with your analytics on this
the last thing that happens is the the
irony is that we really don't
necessarily need life insurance for our
whole life
right so if you've got two or three
million dollars in your Investments and
zero debt and the kids are grown and
gone
and you die
oh I think your wife will be okay
yeah I was looking at it as like well I
can I can die broke if I want to and at
least they'll have this much but I
you're right in the sense that I I won't
be able to spend all my money yeah but
if you put the 95 in a fruit jar You
Wouldn't Die broke right exactly right
okay I'm doing it thank you Dave hey man
thanks for the call wow well great
discussion I thought a whole life was
going to be like time shares where it
just kind of dies over time but Tick
Tock has caused a Renaissance of whole
life agents to start their financial
planning influencer careers you're
kidding and so now so they're like whole
life guys that are trying to make it
cool again well they're peddling it
makes their life cool again you've seen
this index universal life infinite
banking Dave the well thank you this is
the hack wealthy people don't want you
to know that banking is back that was a
scam from like 20 years ago well gen Z
is eating it up on on The Tick Tock Dave
oh so yeah it's caused this Resurgence
infinite banking is code for whole life
that sucks bad that's what it is you
know so the infinite banking is you put
so much in the whole life that it starts
to pay its own you borrow money from
yourself Dave it's do you borrow money
from yourself and guess what there's no
taxes on borrowed money well no kidding
doofus there's never been taxed on
borrowed money let's just run over there
and get you a credit card debt oh my God
there's no taxes on the debt you dumb
butt of course there's not wow I can't
believe infinite banking is being made
Tic Tac just oh my God this Tic Tac
thing is just driving me nuts now it's
Tic Tac according today well I guess
here's the takeaway get term life 10 to
12 times your annual income 15 to 20
years
for sure you can this is this clip is
the start right here oh man this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
on the debt free stage Brittany is with
us hi Brittany how are you hey Dave
doing better than I deserve is well
deserved for this moment right now
absolutely Merry Christmas good to have
you where do you live Little Rock
Arkansas well welcome to Nashville how
much debt have you paid off Brittany two
hundred and two thousand dollars whoa
how long did that take three years the
first two years I had a combination of
my plan plus yours but that didn't work
so when I stuck to your plane it was
three years okay it works for me and
your range of income during that three
years start at seventy thousand and did
that uh just under 200 000 at 197. wow
nice jump what do you do for a living
I'm a registered nurse okay so you just
took better jobs or you worked all the
time or what so I was a full-time nurse
starting out making 70 grand and then I
quickly realized that I could almost
double my pay if I started doing local
contracts and then I realized that I
could do more than that if I took
regular travel nursing contracts oh wow
so you've been on the road I have yes
and some of this during covet yes yes is
that scary it was very scary well uh
a big reward but very scary at times for
sure big reward but but felt like a lot
of risk yes absolutely turned out not to
be but um or not not that bad but
because obviously you're doing well but
congratulations thank you well done all
right what kind of debt was this 202
000. so I had about forty thousand
dollars in credit cards over probably
eight or nine of them about 36 Grand in
uh two cars two car loans 86
000 in student loan debt and about 36
000 in back taxes so why does one person
need two cars
well this person had a teenage daughter
so oh oh okay it's not one person all
right that makes sense all right and of
course she needed a car with a payment
on it all right so you got it all paid
off yes you're incredible well done
thank you how's it feel to be free it
feels amazing I don't know that it has
sunk in completely but
um excited to show start the next
journey of my life for sure so what kind
of got you on this Ramsay way and Ramsey
Journey because you were living la vida
loca I mean 40 000 it was like let's get
some more debt what was this turning
point for you
well I originally found a star listen to
the podcast or YouTube videos in nursing
school however when I actually started
working the lifestyle creep I was like
oh I work hard I want this I want that I
want to do this
um but ultimately
taking care of my daughter being a
single mother I knew that I needed to
change the course for our life and so
I became motivated after that point and
just kind of found the tools and
necessary resources to make that happen
so you're doing ramsey-ish and you said
three years ago you went full Ramsey in
2019 I went for yesterday what was the
switch flip on that why'd you say okay
I'm done screwing around with this I'm
gonna get it I got tired of giving my
whole paycheck to other folks and if you
feel like you're getting progress no I
felt like I was stuck literally going
back and forth every month I had a
budget but then I would Veer off my
budget and every time I went to look at
it I'm like I'm in this I'm literally
going nowhere
that's how it felt if you guys on radio
could see her you could see her face she
made the I was sick and tired of being
sick and tired face you just you just
did that I just saw it you just reached
done done done I am done with me being
dumb that's exactly that's a face you
made I love it that's when you know you
changed your life I'm so proud of you
thank you well done well done you
brought Mom and Dad over here to cheer
you on right I did were they big
cheerleaders while you were fighting all
this oh absolutely I told them talk to
them about every step of the way they
encouraged me every step of the way so I
had a really good support how you do
travel nursing with a teenage daughter I
went well I would fly away to go and
work and then after I finished my shifts
I would fly back home to be with her for
the rest of the week so that was my
sacrifice my trade-off okay so she like
stayed with family or friends she stayed
with family yes okay wow thank you
family wow for real big time support
that allowed you to Triple quadruple
your income yes yeah
that's incredible so what was you
there's a lot of sacrifices you made
here clearly what was the one that was
the toughest for you but I had the
biggest payoff
saying no to friends and family members
because I'm a giver at heart and I had
to learn how to say no and now I love it
it's like cannot no app no
I'm sorry still you got real good at it
you got your no muscle built I like it I
don't know how to say it in Spanish too
nope it's no no you know what in
multiple languages yeah no yes I like it
so that was it saying no and you know
you do you do really kind of get used to
it because when you first do it you're
like oh they're gonna hate me oh
everything's good and you're like well
nothing happened I'm gonna say it again
yeah look at that no I'm going to say it
again wow and then I'm gonna say it to
myself wow because if you say no long
enough you can say yes if you live like
no one else later you can live and give
like no one else you are a rock star
you're amazing powerful lady have you
relaxed yet are you still travel nursing
I'm not travel nursing anymore I've been
back home okay yeah so this is my
daughter's senior year in in school so
I'm at home and you get be there and you
got yourself in a position that you can
do that now it
it's it's it's your the program is is
Heaven Sent it's perfect time and it's
sacrificed senior year I get to
celebrate it with her and I wouldn't
trade it for anything amen now you get
to keep that hard earned paycheck that
feels amazing yeah well done what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is
ooh there's so many the key well one or
two one or two sticking to the plan
you're gonna think that you're smart
enough to beat it and figure out back
door ways it's not you're going to go in
circles when you realize it and time
will pass by and then you're gonna
revert back to the original plan which
works from the beginning so stick to the
plan amen amen that's good that's good
and uh I you know you know in a world
where there's so much information coming
at you and everybody's got an opinion
and a lot of broke people telling you
what to do with your money you know uh
you know in a world like that to just
find something and say I'm going to turn
off all the noise
I got my blinders on I'm doing this
period That's the heart there but there
is a there's a sense of Peace even in
the middle of all the hard work yes
because you just have one thing to do
you got one job you know because you got
one job that's all we're doing and then
you look up and three years in you got
202 000 paid off you're amazing you're
amazing and you know what's really
amazing that daughter of yours has
watched you she knows her mom wears a
superwoman Cape as a Wonder Woman shield
and so you set a standard for her uh
she's gonna be like don't tell me I
can't do it I watch my mama yeah my mama
can do anything and you you told her by
your actions she can do anything you
built confidence into her that you don't
even know about yet you'll see it later
in your grandbabies well done very well
done you changed your family tree yeah
and I know your mom and dad are proud
they're over there nodding their head
right now what I was saying all that so
that's exactly right wow good stuff well
done hey we got the live and give bundle
for you uh so that you can enjoy some of
it and give some of it The Total Money
Makeover book for you to give away and
get somebody started on this and tell
them stick to the dadgum plan and uh the
baby steps millionaires book our latest
number one best seller and all about how
to become a millionaire and that's your
next step by the way uh and then the
Financial Peace University one year
membership as well is in the live and
give bundle all of that's our gift to
you to say thanks to for coming over
from Arkansas to do your debt free
scream in person and for hanging out
with us again we are so proud of you
you're an amazing woman very very very
well done thank you good stuff Brittany
from Little Rock two hundred and two
thousand paid off in three years making
70 to 200 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
yeah
[Applause]
that's how that's done it doesn't put a
pep in your step you gotta check your
heart rate make sure it's still beating
in there man a single mom fight like
that Warrior girl that girl's a warrior
nothing's gonna stop her she's like a
warrior I mean there's nothing you get
that you get some you get that kind of
spirit going I saw it you could see her
face changed right there when she was
talking I thought she might run through
the glass I'm so done you know that
that's when you know it's red that's
when you know you're ready you get a
little bit of Brittany juice that's what
you need right there no one has an
excuse now no you had a plan shut up and
do the plan this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
scripture of the day first Peter 3 10
and 11 whoever wants to embrace life and
see the day fill up with good here's
what you do
say nothing evil or hurtful snub evil
and cultivate good run after peace for
all your worth
Faith Hill said it's not complicated to
embrace life you just have to make the
choice
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five George Campbell
is my co-host today Ramsay fans we got
something new for you our new Ramsay
Apparel Design with your classic
favorite Ramsay sayings to remind you
why you chose to be weird we've got
t-shirts sweatshirts hoodies things that
say on the ship that we say on the show
like better than I deserve live like no
one else cash is King quantities are
limited but you can still get them by
Christmas if you go to
ramseysolutions.com pick one out for
yourself and remember if you're buying
anything representing your gazelle
intensity or anything else any of our
books all this stuff the books are on
sale for ten dollars all kinds of deals
right now at ramseysolutions.com if you
get an order over forty dollars it's
free shipping right now yeah and you can
still get it by Christmas
ramsaysolutions.com
up next is going to be Mike in Fort
Worth hey Mike welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey George hey Dave thank you both for
taking my call I appreciate it sure
what's up
okay so
um I've found myself in a situation this
year unfortunately uh last year in 2021
I lost my mom to cancer and uh this year
my dad passed away unexpectedly oh my
goodness as a result of a surgery he had
um and so it's left me in a position
obviously where I'm going to be
inheriting quite a bit of property and
money along with my brother
um I'm sorry and
thank you and um so
I've never been in a position where I've
had this much money
um honestly I was working on the baby
steps myself I was working baby step
number two
um but now with inheriting all this
obviously I'm just I'm gonna be way past
that and I honestly have no idea
how to handle this kind of money or what
to do with anything
wow
um how much does your portion represent
in total dollars
once everything's uh sold our uh my
lawyer recommended we end up just
selling everything he hadn't liquidating
and splitting everything I'm probably
going to end up between 800 850 000 what
do you make a year now
I make about 42. okay what do you do
I'm a flight attendant an airline how
old are you
30. okay
all right well
um there's a couple things come to mind
um number one uh it is wisdom
to uh know that you are getting ready to
drive something with more horsepower
than you're used to driving and it
scares you a little bit
to not for that not to scare you would
make you uh immature ration on watch so
it's good that there's a reasonable
amount of fear because it makes you
understand that this is important and
it's it's a weight that needs to be
carried it's not a a party to be thrown
right
yeah so that's good I don't want you
freaked out I don't want you overwhelmed
but but um you know if you hand somebody
the keys to a super expensive super
powerful car and they are not that great
a driver they you know they've been
driving a little piece of junk then all
of a sudden they feel the you know like
oh my God I got to be careful and that's
that's a that's wisdom so good for you
good on you for that now having said
that then what we're what we're saying
is is you need some driving skills
and you probably need some people to
ride in the passenger seat and point out
your driving skills and that would be
your team I want you to build a wealth
team around you
you don't have to pay them much or
anything for that matter but you need to
contact them and meet with them and have
them at have a relationship built so
that when you do need them you can pay
them if you have to for their services
so you need an estate planning attorney
maybe the one that did your dad's will
uh it wouldn't be bad you need to
develop a will because you have eight
hundred thousand dollars and you need to
have a will for that okay you need an
investment advisor
uh someone with the heart of a teacher
that will sit down with you and start to
explain how basic investing calm steady
not Bitcoin
you know just good steady slow boring
Investments work how people build 800
into 1.6 million double it in seven
years it doesn't take that much to do
that and that's one of our smartvestor
Pros you can get in touch with them at
ramsaysolutions.com and select one of
those you need a good CPA somebody to
help you with taxes
again you can get in touch with one of
our endorsed local providers it sounded
like there's real estate you all are
going to be liquidating so you need a
good real estate agent in this sounds
like you're going to turn it into money
and and sell the houses that's fine but
you need a good real estate agent not
just anybody in a market like this you
got to have a pro on your side right and
again our endorsed local providers I'm
recommending them I don't I'm not making
money off of sending you to these people
these are people that we trust and they
pay us okay
so um they're going to pay me whether
you go or not by the way so uh
you need a good insurance professional
that is an independent insurance agent
they don't work for just one company
so it's not your State Farm agent with
quarterbacks on their commercial
and it doesn't have a lizard involved
with a British accent
okay this is an agent that represents a
bazillion different companies on all
kinds of different lines of insurance
and they can tell you what types of
insurance you need to put in place so
that because now you have a Target on
your butt
if you're in a car wreck somebody thinks
you're going to be a millionaire and
take your money
so you need increased increased
liability and you need an umbrella
policy and some stuff like that and it's
not that expensive but you've just got
to begin to learn about these things not
panic not be stressed out you're not
going to get a master's degree in
finance we're putting people around us
that are professionals and we're going
to have a little little board here our
you know that Mike's board of directors
that each of these people have special
knowledge specialized knowledge in these
different areas and the important thing
is this every one of the industries I
just mentioned
have a section of them that are arrogant
jerks that want to just tell you what to
do
you do not want a Salesman
that's an arrogant jerk you want a
teacher
that is in the insurance business a
teacher that does Estate Planning and so
if your daddy's old lawyer kind of talks
down to you and acts like you're dumb
and you just need to do whatever he says
fire his butt
you have somebody that works for you and
part of their job is to help you
understand why you should do what
they're saying not just do what they're
saying
is that starting to feel like you got
some peace listening to all that George
well Mike the beautiful thing is that
this catapults you through the baby
steps and the scary thing is this
catapults you through the baby steps and
so as you get this cash you're going to
be able to pay off all this debt how
much debt do you have
um I'm down to about 25
000 remaining I was I was up to about
34. uh until I started the baby steps so
I've cut down about nine thousand
awesome at the end of the day I'd love
you to live on your income don't touch
US money
okay if you invest it and don't touch it
it'll double every seven years
you said you said you're how old
I'm 30. so at 37 it'll be 1.6
at 44 it'll be 3.2
at 51 it'll be 6.4
okay
wow that's just mind-blowing to think
about exactly I mean you're not even 50
years old and you're worth six or seven
million dollars if you'll behave
and you don't really you know just just
you know if you've got no debt you can
live on your income can't you
um it's gonna be hard you've been doing
it and reducing debt
it's true but there's no whining
a big reason I've been able to reduce
debt is because I became a property
manager for my parents as well kind of
as a side job so one of the properties
that we're going to sell
um I was actually able to live rent free
for just taking care of it uh and we
were it was a duplex I rented out then
you need to develop a career that you
can live on
okay that's the other thing which
involves Ken Coleman's materials so
we'll send you a copy of Ken's book from
paycheck to purpose but they live on it
and don't touch this money that's the
whiz that's the wisdom part of the game
well done you're gonna be great if you
need more help you call us back anytime
great job guys that puts this hour in
the books our thanks to Austin Ben James
Zack and Andrew in the booth the booth
dudes they make the show happen I'm Dave
Ramsey we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]